so yes our Wars is essential for me you
know the force is kind of like your
spirit and it's this fighting song and
Darth Vader is like tight so I like a
really case man I think they got like
one of the best laptop cases everywhere
I go I get a studio book
it's triple password it up protectors so
you can't break into this [ __ ] no
matter what you do one of the essential
things is jewelry I do love jewelry and
I try and do it with class you know what
I'm saying
it's from Kanye but I'm Jacob made a
special good music Jesus pieces it's one
of my prized possessions also jay-z just
gave me the Rockefeller chain which is
very very rare never thought I would
really have a Rockefeller chain is like
a journal that I have like palms and
some other art and I do
I don't even write my raps either like I
just kind of think in my raps of
freestyle over Phil yard
I got a few duffel bags got a couple of
wallets I always have to have is a
classic blue DJ 1/2 Japan London
anywhere and I see people with the
Detroit on it is proud because it lets
me know that I am repping a city right
I love the exact name but I know surveys
and I know it smells real good I know
that I probably got like one or two more
deals and I probably would have ever got
off of this you know these are a pair of
fear of God jeans I really like them
I'd be rocking the blue ripped jeans the
black jeans women definitely have like
you know the classic style these are
like the baskets Cartier glasses
especially the vintage frames these are
just a pair of wires right here when I
was able to afford some real cartier
lenses
I had to go getter